but it comes basically from waking up in
the morning and i have uh
three wonderful kids eight five and
three i look at them and the main
question that i ask myself what kind of
world am i living there
now that worries me that really worries
me okay
um because at the end of the day we can
do a lot of things we can do cyber we
can do gaming we can do forex we can do
you name it we can do fintech it's all
fine okay
but my main passion and my main question
that i wake up every single morning is
what am i doing today to leave them a
better world
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opwest hello stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm joined today by leo shalev
the ceo of algae more simply good clear
is one of israel's most passionate
voices for transforming society through
the combination of tech and social
entrepreneurship and promoting the
double impact ecosystem in israel
he is the ceo and co-founder of algae
more an agro-tech startup that grows
fresh spirulina and microalgae as a
sustainable food source and plant-based
protein
algae more is addressing the most
fundamental global issues of the food
tech and agrotech sectors from
malnutrition and food insecurity to the
protein gap and implication of
industrialized food leon welcome to 20
minute leaders how are you
i'm excellent thank you for having me
uh we're about to talk about one of the
most fascinating subjects in the tech
ecosystem in the world so leo are you
ready to talk about food tech
yeah for sure
for sure all right so before we get to
talk about simply good spirulina and all
the good stuff that you're doing in
israel
give me an overview about what is food
tech from your perspective
well food tech
is basically the future i would call it
of
how we can impact the way we eat our
health
and our
ecology around us basically okay i think
we touch ground on all those ground and
by the way futek agritech biotech
green tech those are kind of like
borderline areas anyway i mean they they
they all convene into one main theme
and a lot of the time by the way the
borders are very very thin between them
but basically food tech is is is
re-engineering and rethinking
about how we should eat what we should
eat and what benefits we get out of it
now not only to ourselves but also to
the planet and i think this is one of
the main
kicks for me basically
now if if you're looking at food tech
and some of the bigger challenges that
the world is facing today what are the
what are the some of the interesting
things that are happening in the scene
of food tech
from what you know
so so i think i think um
one of the main themes is alternative
proteins of course okay i mean when we
look at the world today we don't have
enough land for the next 50 years to
grow our proteins okay if we look at the
population and what the population will
be within the next 50 years and we look
at the land that we have
we need to choose whether we want to
grow cattle or whether we want to let
people live on those grounds
now that's a difficult question for me
it's an easy question i must say okay
and i think that that kind of like
pushed basically the whole protein
industry into building different
solutions so it's imperative to
understand that it's not only from the
green side and it's not only from the
vegan side and it's not only from the
natural
areas that you would think it actually
comes from pure logic basically that we
don't have enough land to grow the food
and the protein that we will need for
the next 50 years
that pushes us basically to find
different solutions and in that area
this is the area where we feel very
comfortable and where we work
and and so is this also what what pushes
you to focusing more on on social tech
and sustainability and those areas
so so it's i guess i guess i guess it's
part of it i mean for me
one of the main incentives to do what i
do and all i do basically is all about
impact i don't know anything else i
don't do anything else this one my
passion
but it comes basically from waking up in
the morning and i have uh
three wonderful kids eight five and
three i look at them and the main
question that i ask myself what kind of
world am i living there
now that worries me that really worries
me okay um
because at the end of the day we can do
a lot of things we can do cyber we can
do gaming we can do forex we can do you
name it we can do fintech it's all fine
okay
but my main passion and my main question
that i wake up every single morning is
what am i doing today to leave them a
better world
and it's simply good i find that answer
every single morning basically i i think
we touch ground on all those different
scenarios now i think basically
entrepreneurship needs to come from that
kind of like gut passion it has to come
from inside
you know i i couldn't do anything if i
wouldn't have that kind of like
questions or passion uh when i'm looking
at my kids and thinking okay
what's going to happen within the next
50 years for them
right and so i think that's a perfect
segue to talk about simply good and and
what you're doing there specifically in
food tech in israel
super super so simply good basically um
as simply good i think we basically uh
uh
found the best solution or the best
converter of sun energy okay uh into
protein we're growing spirulina fresh
garlic and we're the only company in the
world that knows how to grow first
proline i'll get into that in a minute
but spirulina as a whole is probably one
of the best converters that you can find
on earth it actually grows in very high
temperatures
so the desert for us is the best area
for us to grow in when nothing else can
grow
no food can actually grow in those areas
you know 65 celsius that's a comfortable
that's a comfortable temperature for us
berlin
okay
um so first of all we're using high
temperatures and we can grow it in rural
areas in very harsh areas where nothing
else can grow second we don't need a lot
of land we don't need a lot of water 98
of our water actually recycled so we're
talking about a full circular economy of
what we're doing not only that actually
the biomass the spirulina itself which
is actually
part of the algae family but it's in
fact actually a bacteria but try and
sell something that is food and call it
a bacteria that's a different story
it actually multiplies every 24 hours
so think of an agricultural product
that actually multiplies itself every 24
hours now not only that we actually do
it across 16 points
spread across 400 kilometers of israel
okay
and we have it every 24 hours the same
product over and over and over again
identical batch to batch consistency
so it kind of like pushes us away from
the agricultural side
into like what you would find maybe on
the yogurt shelf when it says 5.3 grams
of protein i can promise you we will
have exactly the same identical product
within half a year which is similar to
what we grew half a year ago
um so this is kind of like what makes us
special in a way
and and so spirulina what what role does
this play in our diet because this is
something that probably most
most people that are less this have
never heard of
super super so so basically uh the main
ingredient in sadas berliner is actually
protein it's full amino acid it's a full
protein it's equivalent to an egg
actually which is the best protein you
can find on earth by the way
nothing is equivalent to an egg it has
all the different amino acids that you
would want to find all intact and we
actually have 74 protein inside
not only that the rest are actually
micronutrients which are super important
for our diet so we're talking about
vitamin minerals magnesium calcium iron
and all that actually comes in a great
package of bioavailability we call it
which basically says that everything you
eat or 90 of what you eat stays inside
your body
now this is a real game changer to the
food industry a lot of the products you
would find on the shelves
can say x grams of protein or whatever
okay but it doesn't mean that this is
what stays inside your body for example
take popeye okay what does papayas do
you remember
spinach iris right
spinach iron this is how it gets right
the only problem is with this story is
that iron from spinach doesn't have any
bioavailability to our bodies meaning
that physiologically our body can't
actually separate the iron from the
spinach and let it absorb in our body
i've been eating spinach for for 20
years because i wanted to get stronger
through popeye and now you're breaking
every conception everybody eating
spirulina
you should start eating spirulina that
would stay in your body including
i'm ready for my simply good package
now as a as a futec entrepreneur you
know okay great so so you figured out
an an innovative way of harvesting
spirulina in the desert of all places
and what does this actually mean now for
the market how what is the next step
so so basically when when we're looking
at the protein industry what we're
talking about scale okay so we're
looking for things or products that
scale really fast and that's three
generations of protein the first
generation is actually animal based okay
animal of fishbed okay and the second
generation is plant-based which is what
we all know soya beans
p protein etc the third generation which
i find is the most interesting and of
course we're part of that generation as
well actually bacteria fungi algae the
things that multiply really really
really fast okay
um so i think first of all when we're
talking about high scale and this is
what the food industry needs it needs
high scale when we look towards the next
10 20 30 years okay we will have to have
mass scale of products that know how to
multiply really really really fast on a
small land be very efficient with energy
very efficient with water those are kind
of like solutions we will need now we're
not the only solution okay out there
there's 1.8 trillion dollar meat market
only that needs to be disrupted okay yes
we're talking about 40 of that industry
that will probably convert into
alternative proteins within the next 15
years so there's plenty of space for
everybody yeah
so there's plenty of space for everybody
but
only the ones who could actually scale
themselves and be very efficient
on how they do it okay
will be the ones that will take part in
that game this is our theory now we
believe that part of the things that we
will see part of the future products
that we will see and those are actually
the r d products that we're working on
right now are actually analogs okay so
think of meat analog and think of fish
analog so we're actually producing at
the moment in our r d lab smoked salmon
made a hundred percent out of spirulina
it will be in the same color
it will have the same texture it will
have the same taste and smell
not only that it will actually be
superior
to the fish original okay because it
will be clean of
heavy metals
no antibiotics if we're talking about
chicken breast okay and it will actually
have more protein and more goodies
inside the product so you will have
exactly the same feel and look and bite
to what you have
only made out of a single ingredient
which is superior to the original one
this is the future and we are only i
would say less than a year
from taking it out into the market
that is so freaking cool okay so so as
soon as you're able to host me in your
lab and and give it a taste i i want to
take it
that's for sure now
is there any connection you know
obviously you know veganism is a growing
trend plant-based diet is a growing
trend how connected
are those i lost can you can you repeat
the last question
so veganism is a growing trend
plant-based diet is a growing trend how
connected are these trends that we hear
about and and a lot of the activism
around them
to what is now the revolution that
you're describing here in the food tech
industry
so so i think i think veganism uh is is
definitely part of the trend but i think
that the main trend today that the food
industry sees is actually sectarian okay
flectarians are basically people who
consume meat okay they have no dislike
to me but they do consume less
from all types of risk okay it could be
from animal welfare
and from having some sort of sweet spot
to that agenda it could be also because
they actually feel that it's better for
themselves
okay now meat consumption taking it down
a bit and the fish consumption taking it
down a bit is actually very beneficial
to our biology and to our physiology
okay to our bodies basically not only
that it's actually beneficial also to
the planet so based so at the end of the
day if we have
good analogs and good alternatives okay
that will provide us the same taste the
same look and feel the same bite and
also the same nutrients that we would
find in other products there's no real
reason to consume all the amounts of
meat and fish that we actually consume
i see
okay and so
if if we're taking it a step further and
yep and and we're looking a few years
down the line you know what what is
happening in the ecosystem today in
israel besides simply good and and where
do you see us going in the next few
years
so so today israel actually is a
thriving ecosystem in
everything that has to do with food tech
um i see
you know we could we could we could
basically put it on
on the timetable and then we can see
different companies at different levels
uh or or different entry points
basically we can see early seed
companies doing really disruptible stuff
that have everything to do with the food
tech whether it's regarding sugar
whether it's regarding protein whether
it's regarding nutrients and we do see a
very a very big
alignment basically with with health
food and health issues and food
solutions food tech companies that are
aiming towards specific solutions
whether it's replacing sugar
whether it's alternative proteins or
whether it's
bioavailability of different nutrients
that you can find so those are the kind
of companies that you that you will find
in israel not only that actually in the
protein alternative protein industry we
have a lot of companies today in israel
all along the scale basically okay from
from early seed early entry point
companies into companies that are
already in the market for example you
can see the cultured meat industry in
israel i think we have about four or
five companies online cultured meat
um
segments um that i think are
breakthroughing basically
true
everywhere around the globe uh aleph
farms is is i think one of the most
interesting companies you can find we
have um in different alternative protein
companies also you have chickpea protein
you have soybean technology being used
all kinds of technologies that basically
help us
whether it's extract more of the protein
or get better quality protein all get
different nutrients out of different
kind of foods that we find now it's not
only in the future you can't talk only
about food we have two soda like move
also
i i lost you i lost you in the last
sentence can you just repeat the last
two sentences
sure basically what what i'm saying is
when when we're talking about the food
tech industry
we have to remember the borderline that
we have with the agritech world
now i think that what we're doing in
israel is actually reinventing
agriculture
i mean if you would come to a visit in
one of our farms in israel you will see
hardly any manpower
hardly any people touching the procedure
or the processes of producing the food
now you need to remember at the end of
the day when you're growing for example
strawberries
you have people picking every single
strawberry in the field
now let's talk about automated
optimization let's talk about ai
let's talk about big data okay right the
amount of data that we get out of our
sensors
inside the water is amazing okay now
this is the future of agriculture
because it basically allows us to grow
not only algae by by the way but all the
different types of foods that you can
think of it allows us to grow it on a
higher scale control it get better
quality be more sustainable on what we
do harm the planet much less than what
we used to and get better foods to the
table but we need to remember that food
first of all before everything has to be
tasty so it's not tasty yes we love the
game
yes yes and and i think that's a really
really really important bottom line here
now take me back to your childhood leo
were you always into impact is this
something that since you were a kid you
knew that you wanted to do
so actually um
i i had this big dream of uh working in
the advertising industry when i was
younger
uh different
very different i also wanted to be a
fireman at a certain point when i was
really really young and that didn't
happen by the way either um
um i guess i guess since yeah totally
but but i guess i guess since i finished
the army it was obvious for me
that i wanted
to work
and make money
out of the passion
and out of the heart of what i believe
in
which
usually at that time that was like 15
years ago okay
you would basically work at a certain
job okay make money and then maybe
donate or go and volunteer that's where
you're passionate okay now that didn't
make sense to me i didn't want to
volunteer at where my passion is and
have a day job
that is um that basically i'm not
passionate about okay it just it just
didn't make sense now i tried building
different models that would allow me
basically to like put the two
in alignment so that my day job will be
my passion and not only my passion that
it will be something that actually
benefits the world whether it's
education whether it's medtech whether
it's anything okay
and since a very young age i decided
that i will not touch anything that
harms people or harms the world
and that i will only do impact and i was
testing different models i call it
wearing different glasses basically okay
from a very young age i wore different
glasses that allowed me to live in the
world in a different way in a different
perception
and so is is that what inspires you
today this idea that you're you're
building technologies you're building
solutions that are going to help others
follow a similar path whether they're
intentional about it or not
totally totally that that and i think
that building an industry also i mean i
mean those
those are the two things that i strongly
believe in i don't believe in fast exits
i don't
i don't have a problem with exits okay
but i believe that we need to have more
of
um
more more mature companies companies
that actually lead an industry
that are actually building an ecosystem
around them that are showcasing other
entrepreneurs and other and other
companies that you don't have to choose
only the exit strategy okay you can
actually build something that will stay
longer
than us to okay now that's amazing for
me
that aligned with impacting people's
lives
that's it for me you know i've done my
thing
and what are three words you would use
to describe yourself
oh
uh
all about impact
today
all about impact you know
people people people people ask me you
know whether this is philanthropy or
whether this is making money
and how do those two things combine okay
if we're talking about an ngo so we're
talking about donations if we talk about
pure capitalist companies we're talking
about 100
making profits and and and all aligned
with that for me it's all one big circle
in the middle okay meaning you don't
have to um donate your money you can
actually make money
out of doing good and you don't have to
be
100 capitalist you can involve all kind
of socialist models inside while still
giving the proper revenue and return to
your investors at the same time as
making the world much better
much similar to a social business or to
an ngo at the other end so it's all
about impact
back in the days i always felt like a
black sheep in a way
in the startup community i was always
the guy speaking about you know let's do
good and social tech and stuff like that
and people were like dude
the money is in the cyber money is in
the gaming industry
and on the other side on the ngo side
people were saying you know
god forbid you want to make money and
you want to make a lot of money now i
believe that those two can actually
coexist and we need to have more
companies that are thinking with this
agenda and with this dna
i love it so it's all about impact
this was such an inspiring inaudible
conversation i can't wait to taste the
new salmon and and and start getting
shipments of simply good i think it's
just remarkable what you're doing and
thank you very very much stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you so much stay safe thank you
thank you thanks
bye-bye